[Musique]
ceci est une pomme c'est une pink lady
mais par chauvinisme à pour la
mademoiselle rose
mademoiselle rose a probablement grandi
sur un arbre espagnol avec des
pesticides américaine a été récoltée par
un marocain est distribuée dans le monde
entier pour atterrir ici
tout ça pour un croc et 70 centimes
c'est quand j'ai réalisé qu'une simple
pomme avait plus voyager que moi que
j'ai commencé à me poser des questions
et je me suis rendu compte que cette
pomme est loin d'être isolé ses amis les
crevettes danoise fonds se faire
nettoyer au maroc pour être rapatrié au
danemark est distribué sur toutes nos
tables de fêtes de fin d'année alors oui
on peut s'en réjouir d'un système qui
tourne à plein régime d'un modèle dans
lequel on trouve des fraises en plein
mois de février
mais moi je crois que ces systèmes a
aujourd'hui atteint ses propres limites
et qu'il nous appartient de repenser
l'agriculture à travers celle ci alors
évidemment quand j'ai su que j'allais
faire ce talk j'ai pris conscience que
stratégiquement si je voulais augmenter
mon nombre de vues sur youtube où le
nombre de clubs dans vos mains s'était
pas franchement l'idée du siècle
oui concrètement ça va être difficile de
vous arracher des larmes en parlant de
courgettes et de pommes de terre
je sais que c'est pas le sujet le plus
sexy nil plus drôle et encore moins le
plus émouvant mais ce dont je suis sûr
c'est que c'est indispensable et c'est
moi vous poser une question combien
d'entre vous savent que la cannelle ses
décors d'un arbre ou encore que le
sésame vient de fèves que les noix de
cajou pousse dans des coques individuel
pas grand monde mais après tout je dis
pas ça pour vous faire culpabiliser on
s'en sort hyper bien nous les français
16 millions d'américains soit 7 % de la
population pense sérieusement que le
lait chocolaté sort de pissevaches
marron je vous rassure un on parle que
des adultes
voilà à quoi ressemble la nourriture
pour nous aujourd'hui
en réalité tout a été fait pour rompre
ce lien
ce lien entre ce qui arrive dans notre
assiette et la terre où cette nourriture
a poussé la manière dont on la récolte
est produite alors au fond on pourra
dire tout ça importe peu tant qu'ils
restent du café dans la machine du
bureau et bien moi je suis persuadé du
contraire je pense que ce lien il est
absolument nécessaire si me préoccupe
tant c'est pas pour les beaux yeux des
brebis ni pour en justice aux aubergines
mais c'est parce que sa perte à mener à
des choses complètement absurde
les agronomes ont essayé de faire des
races de poulets sans plumes pour éviter
les pertes d'azoté ou encore des tomates
carré pour mieux les rangées dans des
caisses l'agro-industrie injecte un
produit que l'on sait toxiques dans le
jambon simplement pour lui donner sa
couleur rose en angleterre 30 % des
fruits et légumes comestibles ne sont
même pas récolté simplement parce qu'ils
ne correspondent pas aux standards de
formes et de couleurs des supermarchés
en chine
certains endroits sont tellement polluée
par les pesticides qu'il n'ya plus
d'abeilles pour polliniser ils sont
obligés de payer des sommes pour le
faire à la main alors des agronomes ont
fait le calcul qui on devait faire la
même chose en france on en aurait pour
10000 euros de l'hectare
on semble avoir oublié que si
l'imagination de l'homme n'a pas de
limites
la terre elle en a alors comment est ce
qu on en arriver là
cette question je les pose et à mon
grand père qu'à grandi dans une famille
de paysans comme sûrement beaucoup de
vos grands pères à vous aussi
et il m'a raconté son histoire alors
aujourd'hui à travers la sienne
j'aimerais vous raconter celle de
l'agriculture à la sortie de la guerre
des milliers de paysans étaient morts au
front l'industrie avait d'énormes stocks
du poison sur les bras ne savais pas
quoi en faire et en même temps il
fallait redynamiser l'économie française
nourrir les enfants du baby boom on
parie sur l'agriculture les agronomes
ont l'idée de recycler les usines de
nitrates en nitrates agricoles
la synthèse de l'ammoniac qui permet de
faire des bonds de viande du
fertilisants de synthèse
le gaz moutarde sur aussi qu en
insecticides et à travers le plan
marshall
on nous envoie détracteurs américains
mêmes concepteurs c'est la suite logique
des tanks
l'agronome dominique guillet le 10 mai
que moi on a mis en place une
agriculture de guerre ensuite petit à
petit on va intégrer l'agriculture à
l'industrie le prix des céréales entre
en bourse
en un demi siècle la taille des fermes
doubler le nombre d'agriculteurs diminue
de moitié
c'est simple dans le village de mes
grands parents ils sont passés d'une
soixante d'années d'exploitation à 6
ensuite on va s'attaquer à la
productivité des plantes elles-mêmes
on va faire ce qu'on appelle des
hybrides f1 alors l'idée des hybrides
sai je prends deux parents pas terrible
pour en faire un enfant magnifique tout
à fait légitime par ailleurs on a tous
rêvé d'accoucher d'alan glynn mais le
problème c'est que ces hybrides f1 en ce
qu'on appelle résistance verticale c'est
à dire qu'elles vont résister uniquement
à ceux pourtant les aides destinées
elles sont donc beaucoup plus fragile et
nécessite beaucoup plus de produits
phytosanitaires
pire le réservoir génétique et appauvrie
c'est à dire que quand elles ne sont pas
déjà stérile
elles sont dégénérescente le paysan ne
peut pas les replanter alors vous allez
me dire c'est pas très grave puisque de
toute manière une loi interdit de
replanter les semences d'année en année
c'est à dire que chaque année
contrairement nos grands-parents les
paysans doivent racheter leurs semences
à une des cinq multinationales
américaines qui contrôle elle seule 75 %
du marché des semences mondiale il ya
une loi française qui a essayé de dents
d'autoriser la vente et la culture de
ces semences paysannes
c'est l'article 78 de la loi et galim
mais il y a deux mois
le conseil constitutionnel l'a retiré du
projet sous prétexte qu'il n'y avait pas
de rapport avec la loi
franchement les gars les semences n'ont
pas de rapport avec une loi sur
l'agriculture et vu qu'on contrôlant les
semences on contrôler toute la chaîne
alimentaire
si vous prenez le catalogue national
français du cnjs qui rassemble tout ce
qu'on a le droit de produire si vous
l'ouvrez à la page des tomates
les hybrides f1 représentent 99 5% pour
reprendre l'histoire notre mademoiselle
rose
elle fait partie des cinq variétés
cultive aujourd'hui alors que la france
comptait parmi la plus grande diversité
mondiale en un siècle on a perdu 75% de
la diversité des cultures mondiales
c'est une nouvelle forme de pauvreté
alors non je ne cèderai pas à la
tentation du c'était mieux avant nos
grands parents ont tenté de répondre à
un défi de taille celui de
l'après-guerre mais le problème c'est
qu'on a perdu 95% de la vie de nos sols
en 60 ans c'est un cercle vicieux ans
nino dans nos cultures de pesticides et
d'herbicides on tue pas seulement des
ravageurs et les mauvaises herbes mais
toute la biodiversité des sols
ils perdent leurs fonctions et on a
alors obligé de rage de rajouter des
fertilisants de synthèse comme du
nitrate ou du phosphate pour procurer au
sol ce que faisait avant naturellement
en progrès au plan se faisait avant de
naturellement les sols mais on ne pourra
pas continuer cette vie artificielle
bien longtemps on a mis en place en
modèle agricole basé sur des énergies
fossiles que l'on sait est épuisable et
aujourd'hui presque épuisé on parle du
pic de pétrole pour 2021 alors que notre
agriculture en est largement dépendante
l'essence des machines
le plastique dessert le chauffage des
engrais il faut 7 quel horrible énergies
fossiles pour produire une calorie de
nourriture mais on parle moins d'un
scandale plus grand encore les
ressources de phosphore vantant leur pic
dans les 60 prochaines années et
contrairement aux énergies fossiles qui
sont substituables c'est un élément
chimique qui est irremplaçable
indispensable la pousse des plantes
leurs ressources sont inégalement
réparties sur le globe
l'europe occidentale dépend
exclusivement des ressources de roches
phosphatées du maroc
je vous laisse deviner les tensions
politiques croissantes pour l'agronome
claude bourguignon
on ne sait plus l'agriculture ont fait
la gestion de pathologie végétale
les sols sont malades et plantes sont
malades et les hommes le deviennent au
mexique des bébés de producteurs
d'avocat mais sans membres à cause de
l'exposition glyphosate pendant la
grossesse
nos corps ceux de nos enfants en sont
imprégnés
il faut comprendre que ce que l'on va
mettre dans le sol on va le retrouver
dans notre corps
alors pierre aby dia sujet une phrase
qui me plaît beaucoup bientôt quand on
va se mettre à table
il faudra plusieurs bon appétit mais
souhaiter bonne chance alors tout ce que
j'ai envie de dire ça en main ça
s'appelle la révolution verte et à la
gagner le prix nobel de la paix pourquoi
est ce qu'elle est en train de vous dire
tout ça
qu'est ce qu'elle est légitime cette
simple étudiante du 7e arrondissement de
paris alors comme vous pouvez le voir
j'ai essayé la conformité des baskets
plus ou moins réussis on entend presque
pas mon accent savoyard pourtant je vous
assure qu y en a un et jusqu'à très
récemment j'avais honte de dire que je
voulais dans village agriculteurs que
quand c'était la saison de répandre le
fumier nous est dit est imprégné de
cette odeur qui me suivaient jusqu'au
lycée et que sur le mur facebook de mes
amis d'enfance ya des photos de vache
mais aujourd'hui j'en suis
incroyablement fier et j'aimerais vous
dire pourquoi j'ai grandi dans un
village où il y avait plus de vaches que
d'habitants dire et c'est pas très dur
on n'était que deux familles à vittel m
j'ai grandi avec eux les aliments du
potager jamais pris un seul antibiotique
et quand j'avais l'impression d'être au
bord de la mort j'avais le droit à une
double ration d'huile essentielle de
ravintsara j'ai grandi avec l'idée que
les aliments ultra transformer c'était
pire que la cigarette que monsanto était
l'ennemi public numéro un
on n'avait jamais rien d'autre que ça
avec mon frère alors ça me paraissait
normal
et puis on a grandi on arrivait au
collège et on a découvert l'eldorado de
la malbouffe
je peux vous assurer qu'à nous deux on
était mieux organisé que la résistance
où la seconde guerre mondiale on avait
mis en place un marché noir de haribo
dans les beaux jours par d'entre nous
arriver à ramener longue sur suprême
pour un bébé élevés au lait d'avoine jeu
coca cola on avait devant nous une
chance incroyable et on se rendait même
pas petit nos fonds mais mr non plus un
autre âge élevé sont des paroles du
compte elle aussi quand elle est née ses
grands parents est agriculteur à l'aîné
dans un monde qui bouge est dans le fond
de la société de consommation et comme
tant d'autres années a pris goût à 19
ans elle est partie pour devenir sportif
de haut niveau puisqu'elle était plutôt
douée elle a rejoint l'équipe de france
de snowboard et d' escalade
elle a parcouru le monde pour faire des
compétitions internationales
mais il ya parfois des choses qui ne
dépendent pas de nous et un jour lors
d'un entraînement
elle est tombée de 10 mètres de haut
elle s'est écrasée de tout son corps sur
le sol en béton
elle a passé un an l'hôpital avec un
plâtre
partait du glas de ses talons jusqu'en
haut de ses épaules les médecins étaient
formelles elles ne remarcherait jamais
alors pourquoi je vous dis tout ça qu'a
priori pas grand chose à voir
c'est pas pour satisfaire ma dose de
pathos réglementaire d'un discours mais
c'est parce qu'après cet événement qui a
bousculé sa vie elle a décidé de lui
redonner un sens elle voulait que chaque
jour peu importe ce qui arrive du
lendemain elles vivent en accord avec
ses valeurs qu'elle ne fasse pas plus de
mal que de bien la terre sur laquelle
elle avait grandi
alors pendant sa convalescence elle a lu
des tonnes de bouquins sur la nutrition
elle contrôlait absolument tout ce qui
rentrait dans son corps et le résultat
c'est qu'au bout de six mois il est
passé devant le bureau du surgié en
marchant depuis elle a décidé de
cultiver des plantes de montagne et de
nous élever dans un environnement
privilégié pour vous donner une idée tu
le jardin d'enfants sont allés en luge l
école mais je voudrais juste est clair
ok je suis là relou tendance bio et
locavore qui fait goûter ces
expérimentations culinaires aux légumes
anciens de son amat aux apéros entre
copains je boycotte mcdo mon frère est
végétarien et quand j'avais exactement
douze ans j'ai envoyé un mail à josé
bové pour le rejoint dans la destruction
d'un champ de dauger m bon évidemment il
m'a jamais répondu
mais je suis avant tout une jeune fille
de 20 ans tiendrait addiction pour le
chocolat qui malgré tous ses efforts n'a
jamais réussi à rendre le navet
comestibles et acquis oui il arrive de
se jeter sur les rillettes de papier à
noël si je vous dis tout ça c'est pas
parce que je vous convaincre que
l'avocat d'auto ce que vous payez 15
euros ça vaut le coup parce que c'est
tellement plus que deux morceaux
d'avocats écrasé sur une tranche de pain
si je vous dis tout ça c'est parce que
je vous demandais de redonner du sens de
redonner du sens parce qu'on est tous en
mesure de comprendre que l'alimentation
c'est important on n'a pas besoin d'un
bac + 12 en agronomie pour choisir entre
la salette d'épeautre du paysan voisin
haut à celle de du quinoa péruvien qu'un
voyage et des milliers de kilomètres
entre la recette de tarte aux pommes de
mamie et le cheese cake aux fraises en
plein hiver entre le poulet label rouge
du marché et le steak de boeuf élevé au
soja des forêts cela masoni on est tous
en mesure de comprendre que ce que l'on
décide de consommer un impact sur la
terre que l'on va laisser à nos enfants
sur la vie d'agriculteur parfois
bout du monde et sur notre propre santé
si je vous dis tout ça aussi c'est parce
que derrière il ya un véritable enjeu
que si vous êtes insensible au charme de
la courgette
j'espère que vous serez au mans touché
par l'histoire des hommes qu'il y avait
hier
vous savez au fond est quelque chose de
tragique dans la vie d'un agriculteur
d'un côté on leur parle de productivité
à tout bout de champ on attend d'eux
qu'ils soient compétitifs avec les
fermes usines de pologne du brésil alors
ce qui devient important c'est la
quantité c'est la course à celui qui va
produire le plus mais c'est pas ça le
métier d'agriculteur le métier
d'agriculteur s'aimer sa terre au point
de se lever tous les jours à 5 heures du
matin de sacrifier sa vie de famille et
ses vacances pour s'occuper de ses bêtes
et ses plantes
sept responsables de la survie de toute
une population et de ne faire la une des
journaux uniquement quand ils brûlent
des bottes de foin sur les champs
elysées pour protester contre la baisse
du prix du lait c'est pourtant le plus
vieux métier du monde et pour moi le
plus beau
alors laissez-moi vous raconter
l'expérience la plus intime le souvenir
inavouables que garde en lui chaque
adolescent et c'est moi vous raconter ma
première récolte une année j'étais en
charge du potager familial et à chaque
fois que je rentrais de vacances et que
jouer avec les pommes de terre était
prête à tirer que la montre s'est
émancipé je ressentais une sorte de
pouvoir inscrire petits bouts comme si
d'un coup devenue indépendante capable
de survivre avec ce que moi même je
produisais je vous assure que c'était
grisant quand il fallait donc plusieurs
semaines avant de pouvoir croquer dans
la première phrase elle avait soudain un
goût une couleur si spécial que c'était
pour moi la meilleure phrase du tout les
temps sauf qu'aujourd'hui les
agriculteurs c'est plus ce qu'ils font
il élève des des plantes malhabile
peut-il des iep les élèves des animaux
malades ils cultivent des plantes
malades et tout ça pour vivre trop
souvent dans la misère en france en
agriculteur sur trois également de 350
euros par mois pour le sordide un
agriculteurs se suicident tous les deux
jours vous me dire encore une fois on
s'en sort bien en ans et de toutes les
heures il faut réaliser que 111 ans
n'est plus rien si on doit faire face à
une crise alimentaire
on a 20 jours de stocks dans les
réserves mondiales on
de france on tient quatre jours mais le
problème c'est que chaque semaine 260
exploitations agricoles disparaissent en
france l'utopie a changé de camp comment
croire encore en un modèle à bout de
souffle
nous sommes en train de réaliser la
sixième extinction de masse on a perdu
entière des oiseaux des campagnes en 15
ans 75% des insectes en 30 ans à ce
rythme là la moitié de la forêt
amazonienne aura disparu d'ici 2050
comment croire encore en l'argument du
modèle productiviste comme la seule
option pour nourrir le monde
quand un tiers de la nourriture produite
est jetée il faut se rendre à l'évidence
cette fois c'est pas de la mécanisation
et la technologie à tout va qui sauvera
le monde mais du bon sens alors
heureusement partout à travers le monde
des initiatives encourageantes son
entreprise mais ferme de permaculture
des coopératives de petits producteurs
même la haye fao l'organisme des nations
unies pour l'agriculture et
l'alimentation a reconnu que
l'agriculture bio pourrait à elle seule
nourrir le monde
alors bien sûr tout ça ne se fera pas du
jour au lendemain c'est une transition
coûteuses et chronophages
mais il est nécessaire de développer un
nouvel imaginaire de retrouver cette
dimension agricole en chacun de nous de
respecter cette terre qui nous nourrit
et de l'est mais en 2d chemin s'ouvre à
nous on parle d'une agriculture
conventionnelle pour un modèle qui court
à notre perte
il est temps d'en établir une vraie de
conventions entre les producteurs et les
consommateurs
quelle agriculture voulons nous pour
quelle alimentation dans une compétition
qui ne fait que de nous les premiers sur
la liste de la prochaine espèces
disparues sur quoi décidons nous de
mettre la priorité
alors évidemment je sais qu'avec un
discours des 18 minutes je vais pas
changer le monde mais si au moins
j'aurai fenêtre une réflexion chez vous
si au moins un seul d'entre vous ce soir
en rentrant à table se pose la question
qui est derrière cette mademoiselle rose
quelle est son histoire si au moins un
seul d'entre vous retrouve ce lien donc
vous êtes en parler alors j'aurais fait
ma part j'espère vous avoir donné envie
de faire la vôtre parce qu'il nya qu
ensemble qu'on peut dépasser nos limites
nous sommes
7 6 milliards d'habitants sur cette
terre mais nous représentons que 0 01 %
du vivant il est temps de repenser notre
modèle agricole avec plus d'humilité
vous savez d'où ça vient d'ailleurs
l'humilité de humus la terre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]